a new fog huh
let me know if you need support
sir
we shouldn't stick around here too long
we should move
194 for transport
so
the stronghold we detected at the fob is
up ahead chief the redoubt of sundering
inside i'm picking up multiple unsc
signatures
look there the marines this must be
where they processed prisoners before
sending them to the tower
we've got to get them out of here
follow the chief
nice work
gotta get covered go go
moving to objectives
let's move
what's their move chief
out of the way
[Music]
get ready more reinforcements inbound
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
poetry right there chief
thank you
is
i'm picking up one last unsc tag inside
that central holding structure under
heavy guard
um
[Music]
oh
now for our friend
i think that console's rigged to his
cage
glad you're with us chief
[Applause]
guarding the processing outpost
nevertheless
it is insufficient
we must never forget what happened
during the war
a single demon will